so so in your in terms of like your role
in the battle rap world you're kind of
like I was like maybe an executive or
look to us yeah you're like a flash host
like you know like yeah I'm like a West
Coast smack you know what I mean like
yeah West Coast smack shout out to smack
I've made a lot of money selling those
DVDs well they're smack white I'm white
smack you feel me like as long as we're
not doing smack fellas yeah yeah stop
doing smack what was your was that your
uh no no no I I was across the board
doing everything real garbage can head
honestly Kev I believe the reason why
I'm still alive and able to talk to you
right now is because I would kind of
like
substitute addictions for one another I
would go on like have like little runs
yeah this week I'm on crack next week
right I'll I would have like a five
month Coke binge where I'm just doing
coke every day right then when it was
getting too gnarly like I would
substitute it with ecstasy and then I'd
do Ecstasy for a couple months every day
you ever blow some cocaine up a chick's
[__] hell yeah wow snorted and Coke
up a [__] yeah bro yeah I just in in uh
what's that show code
with [__] Uncle Jerome and and
Franklin saying goddamn snowfall oh yeah
yeah first episode the FBI agent's like
blowing Coke up with chick's ass and she
dies yeah no I've never I've never
yeah
true that was cocaine sex supposed to I
mean cocaine sex is amazing but don't
you have to also have a Viagra you have
to have your dick hard yeah because I
heard Coke tits I've never done anything
so so for me being on coke being on Blow
I much prefer to just get my dick sucked
just like because I it might oscillate
from being hard or soft but and then you
can and then you can you know you feel
me if you want to get your dick hard go
to
um
royaltyhoneyusa.com I see you just got
that discount code Lush Uno all
capitalized l-u-s-h-u-n and while you're
at it I have to take this moment to say
we are a very proud partner with blue
tube oh come on let's go bluechoo.com
and get that [__] hard use the promo
code bootleg I will trade you some honey
packs for some Bluetooth yeah done deal
buddy done deal done deal
shout out to the honey pack some of them
taste really good some of them are
god-awful yeah yeah these ones you know
is it an Asian company it feels like an
Asian company I'm not saying it is it
just feels like it this one is a
latino-owned coconut yeah yeah but um
I'm not sure the origins of all the
components yeah I I was because I've
only done uh weed in in um shrooms the
the honey oh my family scared me from
drugs the honey Packs work and I and and
you know I talked to my sponsor before I
indulge it is not considered a relapse
so you can do a honey pack I can do a
honey pack I love it so back in the day
[__] like I was 20 years what's the
best drug for sex ecstasy hands down
again you have to be mindful of the
erection issue you know what I mean so
ecstasy you might have a it it's
possible it is if you ever do a Viagra
an exercise I've never tried Viagra
before really but yeah like or a Buchi
rather or a Bluetooth rather or a honey
pack however
um what I
like a lot of people like really like
Percocets for sex and I've heard that
thing because it does it make it numbs
indulge your senses to the point where
you could just you're gonna last a long
time
I've done the perk dick done any dick
but yeah for me ecstasy and the the
biggest thing yeah pause the biggest
um thing that I miss from drugs of
anything is like the drug and sex
combination and because it elevates your
sex a little bit it did and I had to
learn like I'm so used to being [__]
up since I was 12 years old 13 years old
the 12 actually is when I first started
getting high to the point where I had to
relearn how to do everything sober
normally yeah yeah yeah like you gotta
kind of almost retrain your body yeah
your brain
dependent learning hashtag that to the
point where I literally you know like
having a conversation you know uh doing
something like throwing a ball you know
what I mean like um
you just have to relearn how to do
everything music yeah having sex like I
I was super nervous the first time I had
sex in sobriety because I was like